oh hi hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica I just got the materials
necessary to be able to build a cyclops
- an advanced wiring kit I might even
need to UM not arms and sure about that
how many did I need question question I
need one okay so I've got every other
ingredient besides that one the only
problem is to make an advanced wiring
kit I need two gold in a computer chip
which you needs table coral silver and
quartz now that's not entirely hard but
I forget if I can get gold around here I
forget if it's just silver or maybe it's
gold so either way I got to go find some
silver but I'm pretty sure I'll be able
to find some gold somewhere maybe if
nothing else I'll be able to go down
into the purple area and be able to get
that so I'm very close so what I'm gonna
do is I'm just gonna get Oh [ __ ]
forgot I [ __ ] forgot I don't have a
knife anymore because it [ __ ] baroque
I need to make a knife [ __ ] how do you
make silicon again god [ __ ] damnit
okay I've got the necessary material to
make tonight so now that I got a knife
I'm gonna be able to stab my enemies in
the eyes and also be able to do what I
need to do to be able to get I need
again so once I do that I'm gonna get
the table coral I'm gonna go down into
the purple area and get the I'm gonna be
able to do is when will I be able to
make a modified version of the knife
again I don't know looky there's gold
that's good and I don't know if it's
gonna give me silver okay so I get two
people to go this I [ __ ] my [ __ ] back
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] dude you
were me bastard at least you're not the
big one
I mean honestly though she does I hate
the ocean god
hear me okay so I'm not a I'm not I'm
not too scared that didn't get me too
badly all right father foo okay so now
that we got this we're gonna make I
didn't get the goddamn table coral cuz
I'm a goddamn goof and we should be good
to go all right
quartz god I'm such an heir Harry Baals
back okay who bit me
[ __ ] stop all right all right here we go
there's gonna be the one who's gonna be
the good one all right make the computer
chip bottoming bada boom bada bing bow
make the make the advanced wiring kit
but a bing bada boom bada boom oh and
that is absolutely everything that I
need to be able to make the Cyclops so
now all I have to do is go back to
Geoffrey Billy Samwise and Marshall who
are by the Aurora like the good little
boys that they are which is still blown
up thankfully after I deleted the save
file I didn't know that was going to be
like that or not but I go back there I
get them to build what I need and then I
have the Cyclops eye doc my bumble but
in my Cyclops and then I will have
everything that I need to be able to do
well I need to do hello hi friends how
you doing now good it's lost power which
or am I worried about
hey hey nice it kind rewind okay so I
should have everything I'm not sure but
can goddamnit this a speedy now the sand
shark your speedier than the goddamn
like stalkers holy [ __ ] you cool it all
right but we have what we need
and that is very important so we get
back on whoo
well alright Jeffrey Billy Samwise and
Marshall are you ready to get it on are
you ready to build something bigger sigh
Club oh I want to mention also uh I have
extra titanium ingot I went all out I
feel I formed as much titanium as I
could and put them into titanium ingots
because I know that I'm going to need
plasteel ingot to be able to make the
pressure compensator increases which is
also usable on the products usable on
the C mop or the pran but also if you
want to get the reinforcements module
for the Cyclops you're going to need one
hell of a lot of plasteel ingot and you
need to make the pressure compensator
first anyway I have aluminum oxide
crystals back I might even have the
Cyclops pressure compensator that I
picked up somewhere but I'm not a
hundred percent sure but you need that
so without further ado here comes the
Cyclops baby build it make daddy proud
oh you're such good workers oh you're
such good laborers and I know that can't
be easy to make but I'm really proud of
you guys for doing that so with this I
don't think they've made any
improvements to the Cyclops not that it
needed any Cyclops is already a very
capable ship and here it comes
ah oh ah oh it's lifting oh no I'm not a
goof to bit maybe I should have turned
Geoffrey Billy samurais and Marshall
well I told you about looking around
before you build random giant [ __ ]
oh god dammit
alright hang on welcome aboard captain I
know I'm going to open these storage
rooms online oh I missed that voice old
systems online are let's see if I can
move this thing look okay good alright
there we go
[ __ ] alright ah forget about the camera
there we go rear camera alright the
Ascend out of the way here good
[ __ ] carved a piece of the Aurora out
of there but least I got that okay so
now we've got our dude and we need to
name them submarine name is gonna be I'm
gonna name it unarmed
I'm gonna name it big box very big box
Barry's coming alongside tiny box Tam
which I'm my name I might rename my sub
seem off 90 bucks - bugs name is big
bugs Barry because big box bear is gonna
come down [ __ ] up the entirety of the
ocean down below and I'm hoping that
we're gonna have a wonderful color
scheme to visit what should we do
something noticeable oh it should
definitely be the Big Daddy
- other seamoth so it definitely should
be it should be a giant bumblebee it
should be a bumblebee oh it could look
so guys all it's so cute big box Barry I
need to make the name in black but that
looks [ __ ] good all that looks good
do they make it bigger I don't know if
they made a good run either way
Thank You Jeffrey Billy samurais and
Marshall you stay here you hold down the
fort you hold down the fort maybe I'll
come back if you're good all right let
me just see if I've got anything useful
in here nada nothing in there Lumina
oxide crystals I do need that I can make
another plasteel ingot if I have lithium
which is right there so if I make a
plasteel ingot then I should be able to
make a pressure compensator and then
that'll be one step on the way to being
able to make what I need to make so I
can grind this stuff down
[ __ ] you should do this real quick I've
got eight titanium ingots one class deal
which I'm gonna make the pressure
compensator out of if I don't have it
here which I'm beginning to think that I
do not well I've got what I need there
and one aluminium oxide crystal one PLAs
steel and Ashby okay on that front let
me just take this extra lithium just so
I don't have to look up more of it but
I've got that I've got what I need I
don't think I stored anything back here
did I okay so I think I got everything
that I need there
okay so let's dock bumble but in big box
berry we should be okay
yes please you oh yeah oh yes oh yes I
miss that I miss that a whole lot so now
I should be able to pull the power
efficiency launch will reduce recycle
heat by product to increase engine
efficiency that's one upgrade power
efficiency now four hundred percent so
I'll be able to recycle a lot of power
climb up the other side a lot of Power
Cells
all good that neighborhood so we're all
good there so now comes the job of
piloting big box Barry back home under
the sea and that takes a long while to
do so either way enough stalling
I gotta get this thing back and on the
way I'm going to get as much salvage as
possible to get more titanium and just
basically load this bad boy up and maybe
even before that I'm going to try to
make a fabricator inside this side Club
so that I can get what I need to get to
be able to build what I need to build to
make this thing go even deeper than ever
before the first stop is obviously
getting all the titanium salvaged that I
possibly can and I know I'm skipping
over some of it but I just kind of want
to violate it because that matches well
yay my big box a Barrett is it coming
for ya okay so locker one and
unfortunately you can't change the names
of the lockers on here but I'm pretty
sure you can build things in here and
I'm pretty sure yeah you're able to
build things in here so once I get some
more quartz I should be able to make I
mean why can i why can I build that oh
that's right I can I can just place them
down there I can't build them yet but I
should be able to build lockers down
here that I will be able to put the
names on so I'm gonna do that in just a
second but I want to store all of my
goodies I'm gonna put my titanium ingots
in there because if I fill all that out
I'll have everything that I need I
should have all the timing is that I
need I'm a little iffy in there put that
there I'm just gonna try to get oodles
and oodles and oodles of titanium
because that's what I need and then
carry on from there
little earlier getting materials is lots
of fun
did I am P the [ __ ] out of this did I do
that
let me check yep I did okay so yeparooni
this is the welder don't even need the
repair tool Kyushu ddddd little nudity
shivudu ba ba boom ba ba ba and I'm good
to go let's go get what we need okay I'm
full up God the thing is bigger than I
remember it being cool is [ __ ] okay
could be our baby scoop me up big box
Barry
well I guess I bumped in you I didn't
mean to hold on all day it would be
concerning if they were not so I've got
a bunch of materials I'm pretty much
loaded up I need to somehow get [ __ ] out
of there but I'll worry about that later
I got a drop-off so you get little air
and you get Blair and then you get in
Blair and then I will keep this but I
can make these now sure buddy we'll
boop-boop-boop but can I make up to
stack high if I if I plan this out
accordingly I think I can make them to
high coupe okay yes I can make them to
high I can have so much storage oh it's
gonna be good oh it is gonna be hella
good ah okay
so first up is Charlie Tiberius - who
said markiplier you should really try to
tame the stalkers it's cool I tamed one
swam with it scanned it and even wound
up dropping a tooth from eating the
peeper not sure how long it stays saying
but I hum by itself so we would see if
he would attack me and it didn't so in
the last episode I definitely did tame
them and I meant to read this in the
last one but I kind of skipped over it I
forgot about it but thank you so much
it didn't really benefit me but I ended
up getting enough stalker teeth because
they stopped trying to eat me so that
was good advice and next up is Mande and
33 who said you can distract the warper
by placing down infected fauna you know
the fish with the green blotches any
creature that's infected with the Kirara
bacteria is a target for the warper and
this is another interesting thing that I
wanted to see I'm going to take off my
glove
and look at my hands now they don't look
like they're green and infected just yet
but then again I'm not on of us and sure
if I'm completely clean but it seems
like I'm doing relatively ok I just
don't know how well that's going to do
also I need to make this still suit
that's um that's another thing and
lastly us there's our creation one who
said I understand the pain of living in
the grand reef I put my bass right at
the entrance of the cave to the Lost
River and I'm constantly need to make
runs to the save shallows for titanium
and other stuff also only surviving on
simple things like bioreactor and fruits
and veggies life sucks indeed it does
but it's useful or at least that's what
I keep telling myself I think it's
useful but it probably isn't because
there's multiple entrances into the
inactive lava zone however I will
persevere I will press on because I
believe in myself and I know that I can
do what I need to do so I've got a bunch
of storage I've got a bunch of shy at
and I've got a bunch of what I need to
be able to make what I need to make a
lot I need to get to my little teapot
over there to be able to do the last few
steps here so I need to make a few runs
over there and I will do that in just a
jiffy but not before I navigate these
horrible horrible turns and twists oh
boy I'm I'm dragging aren't I I'm
dragging aren't I
I shouldn't have come to the safe
shallows with my big-ass submarine oh
[ __ ] big box Barry stop smashing up
against everything well I made a goof I
made a couple of goofs on my way over
get it out of my way what was that yes
am i leaking go the long way around and
coming in for cruise ooh
and why I glove and I think we got it
the nail that got it good I did that
perfectly okay so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna load up on the stuff that I
put in storage boo boo don't know why I
did this when I was just gonna go craft
them okay now I'm gonna craft up all the
titanium that I got and hopefully get
the resources necessary to be able to
make a fabricator inside my Cyclops
inside big box berry so hopefully I have
all the materials necessary because I
got a lot of silver I just I got a lot
of table coral I'm not a hundred century
exactly what you need but I think I'm
pretty close and then I should be able
to have a mobile fabricator to come with
me whenever I need it and then I'll have
everything I need to be able to do
whatever it is I want to do whatever
that may be I don't know but I've got it
so that's good
a little hard I can't be too wild about
this I gotta make one I need to make
first so let's see to make a fabricator
you need wiring kit and a computer chip
to make a wiring kit you need silver or
I should have three I do ab3 I have
three silver or I planned this out very
well
wiring kit and a computer chip I should
have both the necessary materials and
then I should be able to make a
fabricator inside my Cyclops and then I
have what I need to go wherever I want
to go I have no limits anymore the world
is my oyster and maybe finally I'll feel
frickin safe in the frickin ocean middle
fingers out rockin pointed towards
everywhere who wants to kill me and I'll
be good
once and for all you cheap wiring kit
should have everything I need
because I needed indium there's a good
question didn't either
I don't remember I did ha ha ha all
right okay so I'm not going to be I'm
not going to be egotistical and put a
fabricator up here I'm going to be
practical and put a fabricator down here
where it's actually legitimately needed
and I'm gonna do it right on the inside
of this door because that would be smart
and if there's one thing Marga bar is it
smells hot okey yes and I can make
Cyclops
pressure compensator I've got a plasteel
ingot right here and an aluminum oxide
crystal which I will be able to use to
make a pressure compensator right there
doesn't even have any sort of a model or
anything like that doesn't even need one
Hey Baby how you doing
then I'll be able to go up here a little
over BAM
oh no Papa shove that in I am the crush
step now 900 meters it's exactly the
same as my prong suit I'm able to go
down exactly the same distance and
lastly I have the necessary item to be
able to make the ultra Cyclops
reinforcement module all I need is ten
plasteel ingot and another aluminum
oxide crystals of which I have both wait
do I look
double check here wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait listen
double check here I've got Duke Duke
Duke yes I've got 12 titanium ingots and
then all I need after that is lithium
and I've got five I would just need five
more lithium which I can definitely find
and then an aluminium oxide crystal
which I'm sure I have back at my base so
I am sitting very pretty and so I'm
going to go on my way back to my other
base down in the depths of hell but
before I do that I'm going to farm a bit
more but I will do that in between the
next episode and this one so thank you
everybody so much for watching I
accomplished a lot in this episode and
I'm very proud of what I've done here
I'm not big of a be the big bucks Barry
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how I'm doing down
the comments below and if you want your
name on a locker inside my brand new big
box Barry just let me know so thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
[Music]